wisconsin senator ron johnson he led a
senate investigation into hunter biden's
overseas business deal as he joins us
all the things i just mentioned senator
you and charles grassley you you came up
with a lot of it short of the barista
side of this what can you tell us about
legal vulnerability that exists here
well it's actually interesting that this
report came out today this is the one
year anniversary of when senator grass
and i released our report
showing a vast web
of foreign financial entanglements you
know so many different transactions into
china yeah we we laid out all the
information we had on barisma but but so
much more has been revealed and quite
honestly our report
really was a catalyst for more people to
come forward mr mick isaac the computer
repair shop owner uh he grew impatient
we you know he was talking to us about
that uh his hard drive but we had to vet
that through the fbi they weren't giving
us information so we released that to
the new york post they made it public
tony babalinsky came forward because of
our report because he realized that uh a
hunter basically shafts him out of five
million dollars so our report was a
catalyst for so much of this information
now coming forward but our report was a
big warning
we tried to warn the american public
that if they elect this very unfit human
being
president biden that he was going to be
compromised that he represented a
counterintelligence threat an extortion
threat and now we're seeing example
after example in this uh latest example
with the
democratic and camp or obama campaign
donors uh trying to maybe do a two
million dollar retainer hopefully they
can get uh hunter to help them unfreeze
15 billion dollars of worth of assets
for libby of course though those
gentlemen would get a a percent cut of
that but that's how sleazy this all was
hunter biden was out this right around
the
2015 time frame same time he joined the
brisbane board they were cashing in on
the vice president's name hoping that at
some point time to be president
is there any way russia china ukraine
kazakhstan and all these other countries
is there any way that they don't have
compromising materials on hunter biden i
doubt it based on the life that he was
living and doesn't that mean that joe
biden's compromised and now that we know
that joe biden was getting his
percentage how come how come he's gotten
a free pass if it was donald trump he
would have been there would have been 15
impeachments by now
well you know the answer that because
the mainstream media put him in office
they're going to cover up for him but
you know what i do know is we don't know
a lot but i know the chinese government
no government knows everything the
russian government knows everything so
these foreign countries that that were
doing deals with hunter they know
exactly where all the bodies are buried
where all the corruption occurred and it
would it be naive to think that they're
not
you know holding that over president
biden's head at this very moment he is
compromised tony babalinsky their
business partner told us he was
compromised and yet the media made sure
that joe biden was elected and now
they're covering up for him
well we need to get this information and
i hear that miranda devine's book is
going to give us more details about that
um laptop from hell senator great job
and we're going to be following are you
running for reelection by the way
we didn't get that i haven't cited yet
sean
all right ron jones for senate dot com
if you want to offer encouragement
uh i'm highly encouraging there you go i
hope that helps if it hurts you i'll
stop it hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else